We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. here's
a voicemail from someone who really doesn't
seem to like Hawaii.
Congresswoman Tulsi Gabard.
Hi David.
This is a really silly reason to call, but
I've heard sillier.
I just was wondering is there a reason why
you're suddenly saying [inaudible] Gabbard
instead of Tulsi.
Robert, I just noticed it in the last few
days.
You were completely mispronouncing it.
Her name.
But that's that.
I can't stand her.
I really don't care if you mangle it into
a garbage disposal, but just wondering if
I've missed something or there's a joke there
that I'm missing.
That's all.
Thanks.
And by the way, I'm that guy who said you
were ugly.
That's ugly.
Only inside.
And um, that's that.
That's all.
You're very good looking David.
Ooh, thank you.
Bye bye.
Listen, here's the thing.
I English is my second language and I've heard
Tulsi Gabbert name pronounced a number of
different ways.
Tools.
See, Gabbard is the most common other way.
Someone yesterday told me it's tool C [inaudible]
but that definitely doesn't seem right.
I'm just trying to sort of hit all the marks.
Either way, I'm going to get criticized for
pronouncing it incorrectly, but I figured
out at least I'll try to get it right a couple
of the times, if you know what I mean.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Um, a radio show has been canceled after a
remark about a nice school shooting.
We're going to talk about who said it, what
happened, the scandal should they have been
canceled, so on and so forth.
And I will again say, this is why it's so
great that nobody can cancel my show.
Uh, you could all stop listening.
You could all stop watching, you could all
cancel your memberships, but there's no boss
that could come in and cancel my show.
And I am very, very grateful for that.
When I read stories like this, we will also
talk about, we've talked about a lot of the
problems about a overnight delivery, Amazon
prime grocery delivery, and those types of,
of systems in terms of what they do to infrastructure,
uh, and to wages.
But there's a study that says that actually
grocery delivery, online grocery delivery
by expanding who can get fresh produce, for
example, could help to alleviate food deserts,
which are big problem that is very much class-based.
We will also talk about a Trump administration
proposal that would allow the importation
of some drugs, some drugs from Canada.
So a very busy bonus show.
I invite you to become a member@joinpacman.com
to get instant access to the bonus show.
But if you are waiting around for like the
real opportunity, there really good opportunity
to become a member on January 1st, 2020 I
have this superstition where I feel like the
first day of the year signals how well the
whole year will will go.
It's not really a superstition.
I'm kidding.
But I'm trying to be interesting.
I'm trying to build a story around this.
So anyway, uh, on the first day of the year,
I want to kick off the year really strongly
when it comes to bringing in new members because
it's an election year.
So we will be offering a sickeningly obscene,
I mean, this is, uh, if we were to be investigated,
this type of membership special might be illegal
in a lot of the Southern States because it's
so obscene.
Um, we will be offering this membership special
on January one.
We will be sending out an email to our newsletter
subscribers.
If you want to be notified about the membership
special, all you have to do is go to David
pakman.com there'll be a blue box towards
the right upper of a section of the website.
You type in your email address, voila.
On January 1st you will be notified about
that membership special, and please
join me tonight on Twitch or a live commentary
of the democratic presidential debates, twitch.tv/david
Pakman.
I will see you there.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].